you know sometimes these uh party houses
involve gatherings of hundreds of people
there are potential super spreader
events for covid 19.
bryce hall and blake gray have been
charged for throwing massive parties
amid the coronavirus pandemic
among those charged for violating two
things for violating
the safer l.a health order and the
city's party house ordinance
are tick-tock stars bryce hall and blake
gray
the l.a city attorney announced the
charges on friday
here's what we know
the tick tock stars each face one
misdemeanor count for violating the safe
la health order
and the city's party ordinance the
charges stem from parties bryce and
blake have recently hosted at their
rented house in the hollywood hills
[Applause]
a bash thrown for bryce's birthday on
august 14th even made headlines of its
own
in response to reports of hundreds of
people attending the party
a few days later la mayor eric garcetti
shut off the utilities at the house
bryce was previously arrested in may for
marijuana possession in texas
just before his 21st birthday he later
opened up to e.t about how the incident
made him reflect on changes he wanted to
make in his life
well i've been practicing sobriety
that's a huge factor in in moving
forward and like
practicing with mental health and like
overall physical health
my mind feels clear i feel amazing like
literally on top i've been working on my
party animal brand i've been working on
so many different projects that i'm
excited to produce
for my my fans out there i came to a
huge realization
when i was in that cell that i ended up
like my father and
that that is one thing that i promised
myself that i would never be like
my father was never there for me growing
up like i prac like literally promised
myself
the past 20 years that i would never do
that and then i i was literally in that
cell realizing like
obviously it wasn't for the same reasons
that he was in there for but like i felt
like him you know
i practice like i promised myself i
wouldn't et also spoke with digital
creator tila dunn
about what she witnessed at bryce's
birthday party well let's talk about
bryce hall and this way house they faced
a lot of backlash for that party girl so
i have to ask you because you were there
just what's your response to people who
who keep saying i see it in your
comments all the time
why are you out why are you doing this
what do you have to say well
first of all like it's crazy to get
comments like that when like i
literally took quarantine so freaking
sis but you know it was bryce hall's
birthday nobody told me how many people
were gonna be there
and i went when it was super early and i
still had my mask
there so i left way before it got like
crazy
yeah i got there really early if you
check my snapchat story the lights were
on when i got there so
people don't know the full story like i
was there for like 20 minutes
before it like got crazy how do you feel
about him throwing the party do you
think he was wrong for doing
doing that looking back knowing i don't
i feel like maybe he didn't know how big
it was gonna be
like when i got invited it sounded
really small like it's bryce hall's
birthday like come through
we're just gonna like have a couple of
drinks so like to me that sounds like
a small kickback so i feel like maybe he
didn't know or maybe
all it takes is one person to invite
another person to invite another person
an address
addresses are constantly getting leaked
and i feel like that it could have been
a situation like that but also those
boys party hard so
i don't really know
you